found you
what are you all doing being secretive
behind people's backs ain't nobody being
secretive we're just solving this case
in real time we ain't trying to give
people [ __ ] updates daddy's friend
junior dude's in the mafia or some
redneck version of it why do you even
care why are you here all you're gonna
do is just argue and ask are you the
damn expert on daddy when you ain't
okay fine i guess i'll just leave but
i'll be taking this
the book is that it's daddy's phone
dummy cellular devices it's what the
police use to catch terrorists and pedos
these days it's got everything locations
biometrics gps metadata
digital secrets there's digital secrets
on there what's on there kelvin digital
secrets judy i just said that it's got
all kinds of juicy stuff in here
probably but
it is password protected well you don't
know his passcode i do it's easy it's
his birthday he uses it for everything
cool plug it in put it in kelvin put it
just yeah plug it plug in his birthday
yeah plug it in put it in put it in his
birthday daddy's birthday plug it
uh
yeah i'm having i'm having a little
brain toot right now
what what is his birthday exactly
exactly tell kelvin um daddy's birthday
well it was june july what i don't know
no
man it's winter cause remember daddy's
got one of those birthdays where you get
screwed because it's so close to
christmas uh no dummy that's me oh hold
on let me google this [ __ ] let me see
yeah good idea plug that
we're way off september plug in this
zero nine zero six fifty two zero nine
zero six
oh dang it what's the problem that was
last week
we forgot daddy's birthday oh dang
oh well
okay it worked we're in
you